la vida es como un surtido de galletas
todos empezamos comiéndonos las de
chocolate, después pasamos a las que
están rellenas de crema y finalmente
siempre queda esa galleta que no sabe a nada.
Es cierto, nadie quiere comérsela
pero alguien debe hacerlo para acabar
con el surtido. Es un deber moral, tirar la
caja a la basura sin habérsela
terminado no es propio de américa. Hillary es esa galleta. Sí, nadie sabe a
ciencia cierta lo que defiende.
Probablemente no será la mejor
presidenta de los Estados Unidos
pero está en política desde antes de
que Jordi Hurtado saliera en televisión
y, al igual que el presentador de Saber y
Ganar, ella tampoco ha envejecido.
Amigos americanos
tenéis que votar a Hillary Clinton
¿por qué? Qué narices, ¡porque es Hillary
Clinton! Porque vas a terminar votándola
y lo sabes.
Hillary for America: cómete la galleta
o será el monstruo de las galletas quien
nos comerá a todos.